i have chased after kids who don't
believe that i am obi-wan kenobi
i'm like i am i am obi-wan kenobi
as they run away mommy it's not him at
all
i saw in somebody's eyes once i was
driving my kids to school
and i was at a stop sign and some like
this is the thing about la you get like
16 or 15 and a half year olds driving
cars
blue pastas at a stop sign and i thought
that was very dangerous because it was
and i pulled up i raced after him and my
daughter was like don't don't and i was
like i will i'm going to and i pulled up
beside him and i started raging at him
you idiot you [__] idiot like my
daughters were going like that dad but i
saw in his eyes i saw the
that's [__] obi-wan kenobi